Gabe says, when leads start coming in on a new ad,
do you get multiple business owners on the hook
from the get or focus on the first?
We've had different people do different things in here.
Let me pour a little bit more mojito.
Oh man, oh man.
If only you guys knew what that tasted like.
Oh man.
Good thing that's not spiked.
So the answer is it's up to you.
I personally, I like to just do one.
I personally do one.
However, we've tried both.
I know there's people in here.
I think Devin Hutcherson, he does multiple people
just to kind of have those backups.
I typically do one and I'll send them like one or two
or three and then I go from the time I talk to a business
owner to the time I close, it's not long.
And I'm always thinking, how can I do this quicker?
So if they're like, hey, let's talk on Monday.
I'm like, how do we talk on Friday?
If they're like, hey, let's talk next Tuesday.
I'm like, how do we talk on Saturday?
I like to shorten my period up and I like to see,
hey, can I close this guy in 24 hours?
So I like to focus on one person and just really,
really like just move fast and go,
but I know other people have had success too.
So it's really up to you, man.